mahogany where you from originally
shinato and Poland right here to lay out
who I've been out here since I was 2
years old
I grew up in Long Beach and I Jenna who
hold a sign freeway
I was I was on Section eight they asked
for an extension they didn't give it to
me section 8 is low-income housing also
hood yeah they actually made me homeless
they took my batch of a didn't give me
an extension I have my I have a daughter
she's 25
I've been homeless for about five years
now since 2015 you're the best-dressed
five-year-old well you know this is my
motto
just cuz you're homeless don't mean you
have to look like you're homeless
you know looks are deceiving something
and then I was staying with summer her
family and then they had to move so I
was like getting put out twice and then
Here I am
nowhere to go everybody's asleep in an
alley so you're not doing any drugs that
are here industry no I didn't indulge in
marijuana
yeah it's hardcore Santino's right here
that's big bro
and yet you just use the mile away
concealer over
not fire farming but don't really want
to be over there because it's crazy so I
also have a significant other so
we are in that out
my story is I did a bad job
just going through being evicted by the
people who gave me the cacao tree you
know I'm not really being evicted I was
asked to move and then I moved but I
didn't move to anywhere I didn't have
nowhere to go but my daughter's people
actually took me and after I sat in the
car I slept in the car at first when I
first became homeless so then they took
me in for a little bit
and after that they had moved so
everybody had to go their own way so I
was like permanently without a roof all
right but I've had a troubled childhood
all my life my parents were married
they both are from Chicago I think all
my I think I'm a dancer there's
something going on in the genes it's
genetic hereditary but I don't know what
so he got molested me
and it really made my brain go haywire I
didn't know I was I was a preteen or in
single single digits I was maybe eight
nine 18 yes I do some of it I don't know
how long he was doing it because he was
doing it to me in my seat when I was
sleeping you know fun to me
laughter that
I don't know how long he's done that to
me I have more questions to ask him I
don't answer sooner you know they're not
my mother divorced them you know and
that's a totally different story my dad
is an atheist he doesn't believe in God
he leaves in the universe but I think
something happened to him because to me
that's not that's not normal you don't
do that to a normal person I mean you
don't do that to anybody that's
something that's taught that's a learned
behavior that nobody takes apart to say
that it's wrong so if it happened to me
you get that to me as a kid as an
adolescent growing up I was like a wild
child
promiscuous yes I have one sister and
two brothers I don't know I have no idea
and if it did they didn't tell me but
you never know
I talked to him once briefly about it he
told me because he was in the industry
the entertainment industry and maybe
drugs or alcohol was involved that still
doesn't justify why he did that to his
only his or his his first darter
firstborn daughter he never taught me
about my birth he never taught me about
men and that's the first man that is
supposed to teach you about the world
and the men in it and he'd never did
that I had learned by myself and I'm
still learning in Seoul I am 22 and I
never thought in their life dated I
would be born holding the son begging
for money I was ashamed at first but you
know I have to eat to know and he looks
a very deceiving I try to ignore some of
the comments it's kind of hard I do if I
had some pennies on make it hell no but
I don't resort to violence we had a time
it seems like once my voucher was taken
from me just everything like resurfaced
just like my whole life just researched
it's like out of nowhere and it was it
was a WoW rollercoaster ride
and I'm still on it but hopefully soon
but we should really all be awful so I'm
happy and I'm very happy that I don't
have to really say I didn't sell my soul
to the streets I eat cuz I do get a gr
check but that's just not enough to eat
for a whole month every month so I
resort to either going recycling for I
don't bake for money and
I'm not ashamed because there's a lot of
wonderful people out there that helped
me that helps me everyday when I do go
out there I try not to wear it out
though because I'm not greedy greed will
get you in trouble so my motto is going
I need you don't need to do that you can
get a job you don't know my background
you don't know the things that I've been
through and another thing is um I have a
well they call it a disease but my dis
is degenerating in my back so sometimes
I can't walk and it comes with sciatic
pain so it's on my nerves and sometimes
we can't walk if I bend over here if I
see too long it hurts so if my spine is
out of whack
it'll be thrown off until it's back in
place in sometimes it takes like a month
maybe two months so
I have two things but no because right
now I go I I'm in mental health I have a
mental health therapist I wasn't
diagnosed just yet but when I went down
to the fifth Street Mental Health
downtown have a mental health they said
PTSD but I have anxiety and I know this
I'm depressed
don't barely be wanting to get out of
bed never wouldn't really want to get
out of bed when I was growing up as
adolescent up until now you know it's
kind of hard to get out of the bed apart
in your depression that is that was the
part that was though that's what why I
am Who I am today because of that
and I don't have [ __ ] but I have a lot
of love in my heart and I love people
and my outlook is totally different and
I know everybody has a story and
majority of their stories have something
to do with something sexual happening to
them and it's crazy how people just
swept it under the rug you know back
then I mean I went to school I have an
associate's degree so I took black
history I took psychology so
a lot of people swept a lot of things
under the rug and closed down a lot of
mental helps we need a lot of Rebecca
and for people like me and that's worse
to me actually because there's a lot of
people out there that's worse
did things and happened to them that's
worse than what happened to me so it is
my spirit the help it does a great deal
of weakening on the human body period
and it's sad you would think that
somebody that loves you would actually
really protect you but their logs are
the ones they're really hard how did I
deal with it every day I don't deal with
it every day
relationships are extraord yeah because
you're early
I dislike
some of the things that need do you know
not again what they do some of them is
something that's taught that's what they
see they've seen it they've seen
anything that whatever they do to women
or that was done to me physical abuse
mental abuse
emotional abuse I can't even give them I
can't even emotionally support myself
because I'm all messed up because I get
so angry so fast and frustrated not just
with me just with life period and people
that know me probably don't know this
about me you know this uncertain ones
get don't certain chosen ones get to
listen to me talk about me so it's crazy
and don't mess it don't date sub patty
has a problem worsening it's hard
my daughter tells me something looking
for love love is overrated but I guess
when something happens to you like what
happened to me and you never talk
you just don't looking for it and
sometimes it's not good to look for it
I'll tell you might be if this
relationship that I'm in doesn't work
out I think I would be by myself for the
rest of the body I don't have time I
already have to take the time out for
myself to try to heal it's even harder
when you dealing with somebody that's
broker Vulcan more than myself
and I mean my the things that people
give me
I don't just enjoy it myself
I help other people too that's in the
same situation as I have so the little
money that I do get goes a long ways
sometimes I've told why do you help
people won't you just help yourself
nobody's gonna help you I ignore it I
still do it
it's probably my problem one of my
problems
yeah and I feel it even though people
tell me I should just look out for
myself I just can't see myself doing
that because I actually somebody took me
in you know and they help to meet so why
not help somebody else in anybody that's
out on the streets
he needs help even if I'm I'm on the
streets I can still help somebody yes I
know I know how to cook so at least I
know they'll be eating something good
you know and actually will remember me
by what they ate that I cooked so so to
me it's a win-win situation
mm-hm in five years I would love if I
can stay focused I would love to have a
nonprofit organization that will ten in
help the homeless I can make sure they
have a good meal cuz I know I oughta
cook you know for the roots or a tent
over there because a lot of people
there's homeless they so used to being
out in the streets so where sometimes
they won't come back big day they won't
go back to what they were in so that
they were used to before they became the
person that they are today so I'm
talking about some type of facility if
you want to sleep outside and it take
you go ahead at least you know that you
can you have a meal you know you can
even have porta-potties outside I mean
that's just something that the people
that's like neither's used to be in in a
in a roof where the roofs over there in
and use the bathroom regularly instead
of in a paint bucket 5 gallon Paint
Bucket we're going to fetch you water at
least it would be running water you know
that's that's what I would like to do
you within 5 years but I gotta stay
focused
and it's kind of hard to stay focused
because I get so like drained and tired
and don't want to get out the bed and
sleep me it's a struggle it's finished
all my life though